un immeuble de 15 étages en flammes en
périphérie de kiev nous sommes à une
vingtaine de kilomètres du centre à
l'ouest de la ville dans le quartier 2,8
au chili toutes les vitres sont
soufflées y compris celle de l'immeuble
d'à côté
quand un foyer c'est un c'est un autre
qui s'embrase finalement les pompiers
vont rapidement venir à bout des flammes
environ une demi-heure de voiture c'est
par cet immeuble du centre de kiev
l'offensive se poursuit sur la capitale
au 20e jour de guerre
à marioupol on en est déjà à observer
les destructions massives vu du ciel
c'est un désastre et à y regarder de
plus près c'est encore pire des
immeubles sans toiture
ici les restes d'un centre commercial la
de nombreux bâtiments en feu sur l'une
des principales artères de la ville un
paysage de désolation
devenu le quotidien des habitants
cet immeuble vient tout juste d'être
frappés et alors que les voisins tentent
d'identifier des survivants
c'est un avion
les avions survolent à nouveau le
quartier il faut vite se réfugier
pas d'abri souterrain à proximité juste
ce hall d'immeuble pour tenter
d'échapper aux bombardements
je n'en peux plus on n'a aucune
information on est au courant de rien
c'est comme si on vivait en pleine forêt
les habitants de marioupol et c'est de
survivre au coeur de cette ville
pilonnée sans relâche les forces russes
8 tous sans exception ça c'était une
école élémentaire il n'y avait pas de
militaires ici c'est pas pourquoi elle a
été visée c'est en périphérie de la
ville que les combats sont les plus
intenses
160 voitures de civils auraient déjà fut
mario paul le ministère de la défense
russe affirme de son côté avoir affrété
des bus pour évacuer la ville